dans la vallée de la loue c'est une
tradition qui attire chaque année des
foules au rythme des tambours les
villageois déambulent dans les ruelles
enneigées pour se rendre sur les
hauteurs de la commune avec ce drôle de
bâtons qu'on appelle une faille
c'est un bout de bois traditionnellement
il doit être fait en tilleul
voilà j'ai un peu triché c'est du
prunier parce que j'avais des premiers à
éliminer et voilà et puis les copeaux
c'est dufresne une faille qui va avoir
toute son utilité
une fois au contact du feu plonger dans
ce but chez les amateurs la faune
ensuite tourné comme le faisaient leurs
ancêtres du moyen-âge une vieille fait
acquis qui remonte au temps où le
village étaient recouverts de vignes
les vignerons qu avait toujours peur
pour la récolte allumé un gros feu donc
au dessus de la colline pour faire fuir
tout simplement les mauvais esprits et
et espérer des récoltes meilleur tout
simplement
aujourd'hui la fête de faith est surtout
l'occasion d'en prendre plein les yeux
ces boules de feu offre un spectacle
saisissant
c'est la magie est et pis la passion de
tout ces gens qui viennent ici puis
cette année ce magnifique quoi avec la
neige
les failles qui tournoient c'est
magnifique depuis ses 8 ans égale teint
célébrée chaque année cette tradition
date and i est d'ailleurs l'une des
rares à confectionner encore les
fameuses fine massa et je l'achèterai
pas dans le jeu et ce seront les plus
petits après moi qui récupéreront pas ce
que je vais la retail et pour en faire
une pour les enfants
donc voilà cette année je suis en train
de former la relève
une relève admirative devant cet autre
spectacle de couleurs qui conclu la
soirée en beauté
[Applaudissements]